junk rat such an annoying character but
so fun to play because he gets a rain
grenade death down on everybody hey
folks Chris waters here with Mary Kish
and GameSpot's overwatch hero guide Mary
Kish let's talk about how to play junk
rat he's annoying
what he doesn't have in legs he makes up
for with lobbing grenades and you so
many grenades yeah and so he's got the
grenade launcher and that thing just
does damage all over the place you are a
serious damage dealer as jumping you can
bounce them off of walls that you're
safe but you're dealing damage to people
who can't get to you and those angles
are really important when you're trying
to take out a torrent or or a bastion
which is a junk rat responsibility you
know he's one of the characters that can
get an angle on those uh those turrets
without exposing himself to too much
damage because he is a little squishy
that's right he wants to stay out of the
fray and that's why he's able to lob
those grenades and also be way more
mobile with his other items that's true
speaking of his concussion mine this is
one of those utility items in overwatch
that serves multiple purposes the most
straightforward version is it's a bomb
you can just throw it in someone's face
and blow them up yeah you hide them
around corners and piss people off by
blowing them up you also can push them
off edges which is really annoying to
get thrown off of the map but you can
also propel yourself up to higher ledges
and getting into positions where you can
lob down grenades on the payload on main
area where the tanks and supports are
duking it out is one of your
responsibilities as junk rat the
concussion mind can help you get there
also it can be used in a little dirty
trick with this other ability - steel
trap yeah the steel trap is one of my
favorites it's incredibly annoying it
actually stops people from being able to
move you put one in a doorway in a
window around a corner something where
people aren't expecting to see it
because they can't get destroyed you
want to kind of hide them when someone
walks into them they're stuck then you
just lob a concussion grenade on them to
finish the job you can you know put the
trap down put the concussion mine down
and then be elsewhere you've set that on
a flank you're kind of it's like you're
guarding that area because once someone
is hit with the bear trap a big warning
flashes on screen you know they're in
there boom you pop the trigger and you
are likely going to get a kill unless
it's a tank absolutely and I mean just
going back to the mobility too though
the concussion mind to be able to jump
over it and launch it and propel
yourself up to another area is so
enjoyable so to be able to just get to a
new height real
quickly it's very helpful for that
character because using your frags at
someone in their face also does a lot of
damage that's true but if someone is
coming real close to you let's say a
tank is like I've had enough this junk
rat they're trying to get in your face
using the steel trap and the concussion
mic can also help you evade if you trap
them they're not pursuing you anymore
and they're also a sitting duck for your
frag launcher also the concussion mind
in addition to doing damage to them will
push you back and away from them because
you don't want to be close to people as
junk rat you know you can do damage in a
pinch but you really excel at mid-range
sort of lob and stuff from a safe
distance yeah you want to actually annoy
people and tease them enough that they
come after you walk backwards and throw
a trap in front of you as they pursue
you you're going to deal damage to them
annoying them even further and getting
them out of the position they were in
we've used the word annoy a lot in this
junk rat tip guide but there's one
ability that he has it's even more
annoying than all of them in my mind
uh the total mayhem he drops grenades he
just like poops grenades out when he
dies so if you ever kill a junk rat
don't go to where he is don't walk onto
him don't run through you're gonna get
hit by junk rat's death grenade it's the
ultimate way for people to learn that
you need to play every character in the
game because if you haven't played junk
rat you might not know that he deals
death bombs upon death so yeah I mean if
you're definitely gonna die go throw
yourself in someone's face and maybe
you'll blow them up now let's talk about
his ultimate the RIP tire speaking of
blowing people up that's right you
actually are vulnerable when you're
using the rip tires to kind of like hide
yourself away but once you've got it
you're just this spiky tire of death
that weaves in and out really fast but
it's easy to control so you can weave in
and out of doors and corridors find a
group of people and you explode yourself
so good but that weaving is key because
you can be shot it can be blown up and
if someone blows up your rip tire before
you blow it up you're not going to get
that explosion you're not going to get
those kills and yet you waste your alt
which is frustrating junk rats it alt is
one that can combine super well with
like Reinhardt's hammer down ores Arya's
a sort of vortex thing or maze a
blizzard you know anything that
immobilizes people get some in a group
get some in a sitting place for you to
blow them all up that's the name of the
game with junk rat blowing people up and
annoying them oh and the RIP tire can
also crawl up walls and jump which is a
fun twist alright folks that's junk rat
have some fun out there blowing people
up and state to
gamespot for all of our overwatch hero
guides